bien dosé squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec mika aujourd'hui et
surcoûts de jacinthe exacto c'est même
le aujourd'hui j'ai trop parlé à la fois
c'est exactement comme quand vous allez
voir c'est vraiment la même plein de
choses sauf que il ya des skins sur un
peu différent et lâche en train de faire
tabasser par may come back mais quoi au
lieu 2 à tort aux os et moyens ça et moi
j'ai pris un tabouret le maintien mais
via t'asseoir notation est amoureux vous
asseoir taille soualem en fait
en fait je pense qu'il faut friant
responsable je m'en vais justement à
l'attenté pas mon poteau elle est belle
elle a eu quelques échanges bien on
dirait juste des gens qui dansent
regarde regarde bien on va le chin
tchèque
ça va voilà c'était le tchèque en direct
aux attendes jouer quelque chose qui me
plaît là bas allez prends le lestant
acteurs là donc j'ai passé ma game là et
c'est d'abord un extincteur puis en
effet puis je vais mourir devait 1
qu'est ce qui se passe bim bam boum mais
introduit même nom mais ben je l'attends
je vais georges est perdu ohlala
d'extincteurs que j'ai mis quatre ans et
s'est promené
l'ag le allez vous en faire toi conte
moi finalement allez viens boire un
p'tit coup à la maison au jeu tu me dont
le net on est il s'est assis je les ai
vus rien rien regarde t il ça soit moi
hop là où le coach pat avec la tête la
balle et est vialattiens moya et et je
sais le faire dans la brio c'est à dire
que je prends mon siège comme ça voila
je viens de la mafia boom glitch boom
à l'époque j'ai pris le bateau le diola
retourner vos productions voilà digne
des plus grands acteurs non mais
personne n'a vu ça mais croise m pas que
je défends cette qui doit labat qui est
à faire je vais jouer au baseball avec
moi
hop là là ça c'était une très belle
partie là j les attentes en mettant lui
la tactique la plus totale tiens si toi
tu toi c'était un homme joyeux ça allait
pas le voyez quelque chose ici était
tout rouge battus pour la [ __ ] au pl oui
je sais ça fait une réception parfaite
quoi aux bâtards non tu as eu là mais je
voulais prendre la main tracts le
dialogue sera pas les cinq heures des
gains illégaux parts à l'état bon je
suis mort hop là hop la revoit autour du
cou allez ola olé les solutions réseaux
ou là moi franchement j'avoue je
retourne à ses yeux les jeux mais je
crois que je rentre dans ma cellule
voilà où là on sa coupe la patrie que tu
tentes un guet-apens mika mekkaoui tu as
we mouvement qu au tu t'envoles moi tous
mes coups de peter pan ce n'est pas
peter pan qui je me mette un coup
maintenant tu me dis comme ça du tabac
moi je t'aime pas je pense qu'on peut en
dire autant bien on essaie de rentrer
tant bien décevant prévoit très bien on
essaie de rentrer à hauteur là juste là
vient mais c'est de rentrer voir fait
pas qu'on essaye de rentrer pour moi la
bbc de rentrer mais calme on essaie de
rentrer quand même année il va donc
excellentes ml on essaie de rentrer mais
qu'as tu fait non mais rien je veux
juste aller par là pour boire non s'il
te plaît s'il te plaît mais on a mal on
n'en dégage
ouais demandez moi le moi j'avoue je
m'en vais alors la remontée elle est
bien ou pas par la remontée de ton point
dans mon nez en fait on va faire l'objet
plus dit m je pense convoquer détail la
8e journée
de dany boon on l'attend on retire tes
mains non mais ça ne dérange parce qu'il
ya la souris qui est là en fait bien
évidemment à la foire et non mais là il
faut changer niveau correct et sérieux
avec kim aux poteaux quoi hakim pop up
là je te roule à un akin peau non je
crois que barcelone et madrid ont été un
peu plus forte en fait j'aurais passé du
touladi le poteau c'est bien toi tu vas
faire tu vas faire le coup le sort du
barbare dans diablo quoi déjà tombé sur
toi avec les deux boîtes est mort non
tout ça scandaleux je suis outré bah je
me demandais attend l'attesté attend les
esters attendant je tâche de terre
battue comme ça voilà tu es mort allez
fais moi c'est gagné non c'est moi qui
gagne tu m'as mis le doute en plus en
plus amusé à boileau veulent regarder
ces labels label franquette photo vs
tabouret et tard c'est un guet-apens un
plat aux mollahs en plaques est ce tu
vas faire mon gars c'est pareil non mais
c'est que c'est tout tu essayais pas de
prendre la balle de baseball par tout
hasard
non c'est ce que tu essaies de faire
malheureusement ça s'est mal passé pour
nora décédées n'ont hélas vrai même
rengaine en plus c'est à dire quand u17
comme ça tu fermes ta gueule
bon la vraie vraie vraie belle
franquette dans un an oui oui oui oui
oui c'est pas grave on est les deux et
on aime l'europe ait eu pas flagrant
délit en train de toucher pour toi tu la
plus marquée est d'ailleurs si de la fin
de cette vidéo sur comment s'appelle ce
jeu déjà s'appelle généralise oubari
exodo voilà c'est marqué juste sur cette
fenêtre rester à regarder mais stepanek
jo ça vous appuyez ensuite aux tv dans
une prochaine parce que c'est la
politesse tu as tout le monde a
[Musique]
à la barre jean dick est surtout propre
sud est y étudient aussi la planète
[Musique]